Al I testify itif that none that none
has the right the right to be worshiped
to be wor except ex Allah since the
start of Ramadan in the first N9 days
alone 222 people have accepted Islam
from this Masjid this was not always the
case in this violent area German Town in
Philadelphia USA has a notorious
reputation one that manages to stain
every good that comes out of the Town it
is notorious for violent crimes of All
Sorts but the most prominent is the
incessant shootings although
Philadelphia is synonymous with violent
crimes the rate at which it occurred in
germant town was higher compared to the
surrounding areas what changed and why
in
2015 the German Town M mid was
established considering their
environment the patrons of the Masjid
knew they had their work cut out for
them whatever good they planned to
achieve was always going to take some
time and effort but they didn't shy away
from The Challenge in
2021 German Town experienced one of its
worst violent periods in its over three
centuries history contributing a
significant part to the highest crime
rate ever recorded in Philadelphia
history there were shootings and other
forms of crimes virtually every other
day while the Muslim Community in the
town have been consistent in their
effort to arrest the violent situation
and Achieve peace an unforgettable event
happened that would stay forever in the
memory of the umah in Germantown mjid it
was a wake-up call not that they were
sleeping but but this was on a different
level in September of 2021 there was a
shooting right in front of the German
Town musjid although the sounds of
gunshots are not strange to the people
of germant toown it is a different ball
game when it is right in front of you
several shots were fired within a short
time and it left four victims one dead
three seriously wounded the Imam and
members who were in the mosque for a
program rushed out to help the wounded
with their clothes soaked in blood they
did all they could to help the victims
get medical aid until the police arrived
after three people are shot one person
killed the gunfire rang out near a place
of worship and the leader of that mosque
was among the first on the scene helping
the victims any way he could Sunday
night I'm Walter Perez the big story on
Action News is the investigation just
getting underway into a deadly trip
triple shooting it happened in German
toown this afternoon in front of a
mosque and tonight we have an exclusive
interview with the Imam who helped the
survivors initial reaction was that you
know Sunday is the one of the busiest
days for us we have hundreds of
attendees of our mosque in the area so
possibly it could have been a woman or
it could have been a child Imam Hass
Abdi says he was in a neighboring
bookstore when he heard the gunshots he
and other Good Samaritans rushed to the
scene and helped load the victims into
private cars it was a human being and
they were laying on the floor so we
tried to get them the help you know that
we were able to give and trying to get
them to the hospital shootings like that
continued and in December 2021 another
one happened and the Muslim Community
have had enough this time in a nighttime
shooting 87 shots were fired leaving
several people wounded sleep eluded many
and first thing in the morning it was
the Talk of the Town the people have had
enough but they had little to noice
Choice the Muslim Community came to the
Forefront of efforts to bring peace to
the Community Police say a group of
people were standing at the corner when
this white van pulled up and six people
got out shooting at the group on the
corner several members of the group
returned fire the initial Shooters got
back in the van which was last seen
traveling westbound on Germantown Avenue
with a rack on the roof and distinctive
graffiti on the passenger side today
members from Germantown mosque stood in
solidarity fed up with the gun violence
in their neighborhood no doubt it's
alarming and it appears to be more like
a war zone it's been a violent year with
a record number of homicides we're not
standing for this
nonsense you know you have Muslim dayc
carees over here you have the bike shop
across the street that been here for
years these people want peace and they
want Security in their neighborhoods we
they want peace and they want Security
in their neighborhoods we're not
standing for this nonsense it's sad is a
shame that we have to deal with this our
children their lives is in Jeopardy we
have a bullet that went through a
daycare across the
street we're here to establish Security
in our neighborhood not just for the
Muslims but all of our neighbors
Germantown Avenue and all the city of
Philadelphia we have to stand for
something since then germant toown
musjid intensifi their efforts to rid
the town of violence
and the fear that comes with it they
have purchased abandoned buildings that
housed criminals and turned them into
business Outlets or for Community use
following some advice of the
imali and some of the elders in the
community uh we purchased another
building here on gertown Avenue one of
the buildings that you know uh hared a
lot of uh nonsense and you know uh young
lot of the young kids grouping up here
in the community uh you know we decided
to get this Chinese store uh along with
a few of the other builders on the
Avenue here so you know insh tal the
building will be a benefit to the
community in the future the near future
inah tal um Ramadan 20124 started and to
consolidate on their efforts over the
years the germant toown Masjid
intensified its daa Outreach and the
results are simply outstanding score of
people have been taking the shahada
daily and became Muslims violent
individuals are renouncing their violent
ways choosing peace
instead
Ramadan this month of Ramadan that is
being legislated by
Allah so that we may be Pious so that we
may be
Pious the poet he said Allah has
intelligent Serv
they looked at this world and they
divorced it because when they looked at
it they recognized that this is not a
place where people will live forever
it's time for those people who are
running the streets to divorce it what
if the streets given you what money what
is it brought for your children are they
successful academically more importantly
religiously what has it done for you
what have the streets done for
you Allah has intelligent servants who
are they
they divorc this world because they fear
the tribulations and the trials that's
going to come behind it some the only
thing the streets brought them was
either they lost children they ended up
in prison or they destroyed families or
they destroyed somebody else's family
the streets are cursed everything
relating to the streets are cursed and
if you're involved in it you're involved
in a lifestyle that is cursed whether
you like it or not we're not here for
votes we're not here for likes we're
here to convey what Allah said what the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said and because we want good for every
single one of you but how can we want
good for every anyone if we're not going
to tell people the truth yes we welcome
everyone doesn't matter where you are or
what stage you're at but at the same
time as we mentioned in the beginning
the truth is above all of
us and they advise one another to be
patient
look completing ourselves complete
helping our
communities I believe alhamdulillah to
be honest with you the things I'm seeing
and the people alhamdulillah around us I
believe change is coming for our inner
cities may Allah you know grant us all
success right is that they have
requirements to get a permit to get
training to report your missing weapons
these life-saving laws that we have
evidence will prevent the next shooting
perhaps the most impactful piece to
reducing gun crimes is involved
community members and Faith leaders like
Imam Hassan Abdi with the Germantown
Masjid our faith instructs us to improve
the area for ourselves and our neighbors
whether Muslim or non-muslim the
neighborhood surrounding the Masjid has
been plagued with crime the violence
recently erupted right in front of the
place of worship and we heard a shooting
we run outside the mosque uh we go to
the corner sadly we see somebody you
know was shot and he ended up dying the
Imam is fighting crime by Taking Back
the block the mosque has purchased
surrounding properties and turned them
into restaurants a convenience store and
a bookstore even an apartment building
the faith leader then made an
unconventional decision and we hired
private security it was not the ideal
thing to do but we provided it for the
you know the entire area especially the
businesses and we noticed the change
can't just make sure y was good as a
community if we're invested in our own
areas then I think we're more involved
in the change rather than expecting
people people to come from the outside
and do it for us and that's what it's
about being a part of the change some of
the da activities and some of the the um
the lessons that are going on um in in
your mjid in German toown um and also
here as well
in at the moment in ger there are
numerous lessons in a number of
different Islamic Sciences for example
the Arabic language Medina book one
likewise in the
moment I teach that every Saturday we
have the explanation
of as it relates
to
teaching summarize jur Prudence
by just completed the summary
of that was every Tuesday we have uh on
the
weekends which is an explanation of
collection of similar to like 40 in
addition to you know the Quran classes
alhamdulillah and the classes for the
children
[Music]
in
ald
[Music]
we only prostrated God we don't bow to
no human being we don't prostrate to any
human being or any created thing because
that's the wor sin sh meaning associate
partners with him bowing his worship
prostrating His worship and that's why
you know we don't prostrate to any man
that's why a Muslim doesn't fear any man
that's why I was saying to the brother
like Isam after me right
ASU Allah I testify I testify that none
that has the right the right to be
worshiped to be worshiped except Allah
[Music]
except and I testify ttif that Muhammad
is the messenger of Allah the m
you